one of the things that we've talked
about a couple times on
on facetime with respect to you know
being a dad
is the challenge of trying to figure out
like what that means in 2021
right you're no longer don draper
who's going out and doing whatever as
long as you're paying for everything
right um you can't just be the super
sensitive guy
you're expected to be strong but also
emotionally available and vulnerable
at just the right time right you have to
be the good listener but you also have
to be the person
who knows how to erect the boundaries
well making uh you know a living that's
going to support the people right
right that you share a home with right
and
it could be overwhelming and confusing
to know what that roadmap
looks like for you uh yeah
i think it's i think it's a stress that
it's also not cool to
complain about you know like there's not
much of a space for
meant to be like wow this is a lot you
know yeah i think you're supposed to
you're supposed to have you're supposed
to
i got this you know you're supposed to
you know beyond so
yeah it's it's complicated i mean being
yeah i got
like that's part of that is yes and part
of that is part of the problem
for sure what i mean like just for sure
i'm just gonna buckle down and solve the
problem
yeah isn't necessarily how you solve the
problem
right and then and then and then what
stereotypes do we
continue like supporting and like what
do we still think is like the husband
role thing like for example like around
the house [ __ ] like i didn't really want
to necessarily move the birds we did
and like now we've got this house and
the house has like a water heater what
the hell's a water like furnace i don't
know i'm just saying things now a sink i
knew that one before
uh carpet wood floors things so so okay
a lawn okay now
i've got a my shirt's tucked in it says
loomis dad i'm pushing a lawnmower it's
all coming it's all coming to life
but i i've i've gotten some shade from
like the moments where goldie is like
hey can you can you fill in the blank
build the dresser or like hang the
lights or like the thing and like
i can't do it i can't do that stuff and
then i grew up in a house
where i could we're kind of always doing
projects and things but like
so it always especially in my new like
suburban house life it feels like
fail to like call like a real guy
with a tool belt and he owns the saw
to come saw my stuff right the washing
machine breaks or whatever
totally yeah and so like as if as if we
buy a house and the dad then knows how
to fix a dryer
same day it's like what are you talking
about so so
i think pushing back so so it would be
like you know the stereotype and i tell
goalie this when she's like are you
pissed and i'm like yeah she's like
we'll explain yourself i'm like i don't
know
like you know that's like a dad thing i
should be able to
replace the ceiling fan or something you
know and a lot of my homies just being
disappointed in yourself because you
feel like you don't you can't live up to
that
that's the role stereotype yeah yeah
yeah and then
um and i threw it back in her i was like
that would be like me saying your
cooking sucks like you can't cook
and then she's like well i can and i'm
like yeah [ __ ]
yeah you're a pretty good cook okay
maybe i should learn how to fix the
ceiling fan you know these stereotypes
like what our roles are and so
um i mean going back to just the
one-on-one time with your kid putting
your phone down
and like how you talk to kids like the
the generations before us and also some
of us had parents
that didn't have all those conversations
but didn't didn't weren't so open
and you know i really admire the parents
who
have a relationship with their kids
where you know
for most of their childhood for sure
maybe up until their teenagers
are coming to their parents and asking
questions right yeah and if you don't
have that communication open who's that
on
right yeah mother or father or whatever
like i think that's on the parent
so those are some good goals that fall
outside of the roles and the stereotypes
it's just like
i think i can do that i do a lot of my
friends not allowed my guy friends
you know and so one of the things i've
learned
as i continue to try to figure out this
parenting thing
i've said this before but the older boys
are my stepsons
i had a hand in helping you know
navigate them into young men but i
wasn't their dad
but i was around all the time right so i
feel like on some level i participated
in right do they know their dad um
yeah and he's since passed away and and
their dad was great and he was a great
dad yeah yeah
so i was always very you know respectful
and cautious
sure sure overstep that boundary um
with these next two
who are my children it's been a lot
harder
and when i thought i had a grip on what
parenting was
i'm continually challenged and brought
to my knees yeah as i would have never
imagined
and one of the things that i've learned
to get back to
my original point is no matter what you
do
like that pendulum swings back and hits
you in the ass sure so when you're like
i'm going to be the open
dad totally tells them all this stuff
they reach a certain age and they're
like why are you telling me all this
right you're like you're angry that like
you're an idiot you should just be like
i just need to know that you've got it
under control
right you know but if you were that guy
then they'd be like why didn't you tell
me
you know it's like it's it's rigged in a
way that
you're you're not gonna win right right
you're in a you're in this like weird
mouse labyrinth
right that only leads to like you know
damage control
right right right and learning how to
like come to terms with that and be okay
with that
has led to you know a lot of pain but
also some hilarious conversations
and is that for uh for the two younger
kids
was that always
that feeling or was it mostly teenage
years no this is
this is this is all kind of coming out
yeah rich teenage you know
they reach a level of sentience and and
and look
kids will try to identify by either
um becoming more like you
like they're gonna they're gonna take
your lead and look up to you and be like
i want to be like dad or i want to be
like mom
or they try to craft their identity in
opposition to him
right so we're in that right now right
right where it's like whatever we're
doing right that's that's definitely the
wrong way to do things
right and they have to figure it out for
themselves and as a parent you're like
well let's give them that opportunity
because you want them to push you know
their boundaries and figure out like
what works for them and what doesn't
like that self-exploration that
differentiation that
you know trying to figure out who they
are in the world totally as they get
older
totally but at some point you got to put
the guard rails up right but where do
those go
like it's just it's so stressing me out
confusing that stressing me out
let's go back to that i said to you like
when you when you said like oh we
you know we're we're going to have
another baby i'm like good well in 15
years
15 years from now you'll be going
through it totally
totally no there was definitely like you
controlled some of this story you
controlled the pacing on this which was
like
you you said some very sweet things over
the years we were like oh i remember
washing my kids in the sink and time
flies
and when i see you with lumi i miss that
yeah you know it's like i'm i'm not in
that station and i have to remember so
precious
and just being a hundred percent present
for that yeah it's
it's such a cool yeah yeah yeah
and then like i just like it cracks me
up like i met like for whoever's lives
on this imagine if ritual was your dad
like how wild is that
like and then you talk about the
pendulum swinging like so like what so
like they're eating beef nachos like and
they're like just they think you're you
they think your [ __ ] is just terrible
basically yeah you don't know but one of
the funny things that julie julie and i
will then go
like when we're talking about it she'll
be like
what will this joke be like there's all
these people out in the world
they would love for us to be their
parents
totally totally because you know this
thing like younger people do
um it's like internet speak in youtube
comments they'll just say dad
yeah you know like dad like oh like
you're the mentor that i need in my life
totally so i get those comments on you
like dad
dad dad yeah and i was like but my kids
they're like
bonehead no bueno yeah totally totally
totally nothing but i mean were you um
when you were a teenager what kind of
teenager were you
i was i was a um super goody two shoes
were you
yeah i was a grinder i mean i was i got
into i mean when i was
around 14 is when i started to get
serious about swimming so it was all
about swimming and then it became all
about school
and i was very judgmental of anybody who
was like out having fun and messing
around because i was like
very directed yeah but i was also
socially awkward
right i was you know
not a not a not a good looking kid yeah
you were socially distancing
back in that yeah yeah yeah you're way
back i was in og yeah
yeah you started this whole thing yeah
you know i had weird-looking glasses
yeah yeah you still did a bad haircut
and you still do so yeah yeah right
no i mean like that's that's the thing
that i i'm fearful of is you know i mean
i was a really bad teenager like
going back to the harvard statement
stadium comments and the commentary
about race it's like
we would bend and break every rule like
the the story and
you know i only have one other other
sibling an older brother's two years
older
and he was a little closer to your end
just he he didn't break as many rules
but like
you know i was this big i was this big
when i was 15 and a half years old
wow that's a lot of energy and so my
folks are divorced and so i spent time
in both houses but like
my mother had her hands full with us and
so
i just think about how i used my
creativity and my energy
back then i had a lot of it social
connections i had a lot of like
traditional popularity and i used all of
that to like
[ __ ] around and so how did you
slowly emerge out of that um
[Music]
how did i slowly emerge out of that
it was a couple decisions towards the
end of high school
in what felt like really last chance
opportunities and going back to the
commentary on race like
this world wouldn't have been as uh
patient or kind to
some of the things i did and got away
with if i weren't a
loud charismatic white kid captain the
basketball team kind of like that guy
i got into rowing at the end of high
school i barely graduated high school
but i got into rowing because people
said like you'd be pretty good at it and
there's college opportunity maybe
but whatever and i got into acting in
high school mm-hmm
other than that yeah you talked about we
talked about that on the first podcast
that's the like less known that's the
yeah that's
the b plot yeah yeah yeah yeah you could
have gone this whole
acting trajectory maybe i'm too big i'm
too big but anyway so so
so i picked up i got into acting in my
senior high school i got into rowing
and these were two like cult worlds on
their own and i and they both grew very
quickly and they both
were taking me away from that that idea
of
i just didn't you know i was kind of
overdriven so then college became a
thing and then boston became a thing and
then i was surrounded with a bunch of
definitely not straight laced but like
goal-driven
rower type kind of preppy kind of
hardcore
like uh jock dudes right college
division one college athletes you know
and from there you kind of watch a
winklevich
100 those guys are out there um and so
so yeah so that was
that was it but you know we still played
in the margins and saturday night still
came and like so
when it comes to being a dad now it's
like i don't i
wouldn't i would be freaked out if i had
if he saw my playbook you know what i
mean
when it comes to like ruckus so
anyway we'll see to be continued yeah
but you know the universe god whatever
you want to call it riggs it in a
certain way that
you'll get your your buttons pushed and
you'll get challenged
in ways that you can't foresee totally
what i mean and it's like it puts right
in front of you whatever it is that you
need to look at within yourself
100 now and i love that i mean the
challenge of being a dad right it's
the hardest thing i've done and it's i
have a friend who's about to become a
dad in like a couple months
it is also there's no second place
there's not even like there's no podium
it's like the first second and third
best thing i've ever done right so it's
so cool right yeah
and it's the hardest it's so hard you
just give up everything
i'm not complaining
[Music]
you